I am told there are many who have
tattoos of the uniform inscription the
ammaji I have witnessed a few but only a
few Pierre Goodrich was a
multi-dimensional human being a very
successful businessman he was a Harvard
trained lawyer it was this curious
nature in him in particular driving him
to understand what it is in man's nature
that once man that wants to be free he
pursued his curiosity to this thing
called freedom all the way back to the
earliest known depiction of the word
freedom and that had that was in the
2300 BC comes from an ancient tablet can
a form inscription of the ammaji or the
the oldest known word for freedom
Liberty fund was founded the the
official date is August 18 1960 so two
years ago we went through the year of
2010 celebrating the Foundation's
fiftieth anniversary in the early years
well mr. Goodrich died in 1973 so he was
involved in continuing to develop the
idea of Liberty fund for about 13 years
in those 13 years he was responsible for
organizing and or participating in 10
conferences of the general themes and
topics running through those 10
conferences at the time was education a
very strong interest of mr. Goodrich and
his colleagues a war in international
relations money and monetary inflation
and issues of federalism power power in
the executive power and the judiciary
power in the Congress we now do about
180 to 190 conferences a year in North
America in Latin America in Europe and
some in Asia and the general construct
of a conference is their Socratic in
nature that is the Scrat ik discussion
the discussion is usually over two days
a total of about nine hours of
discussion three one-and-a-half hour
sessions on a Friday for example and
then three more on a Saturday lunches
dinners are important part
the downtime are important part of a
conference experience as much
conversation takes place during those
times during a conference weekend as at
the act of the formal sessions our
conferences are characterized as well
this is what we thought graduate school
is going to be like so it's providing a
forum in that sense that doesn't exist
on anywhere else that I know of knew us
but we also have three educational
websites the oldest is the library of
economics and liberty
econ Lib for short and we remain very
active there with feature articles book
reviews a repository of books on
economics curriculum ideas for teachers
our publishing activity has accumulated
a catalog with about 400 titles keeping
in print or bringing back into print
important works that have the ideas in
this in the development of classical
herbalism and its contribution to this
great experiment in Liberty particularly
in the United States looking back at
those authors who kept this conversation
going about freedom I think I think that
it would be safe to say that that the
issues were as are as important now as
they ever have been and will likely
always be worth discussing